Make javascript great again.
Hello world,
it's to Raj and Google recently
announced the much anticipated javascript
version of its popular machine
learning framework, tensorflow,
dubbing it tensorflow dot j s.
In this video,
we'll use it to build a very simple web
app that can detect any object you show
your Webcam.
Last year,
the Google brain team developed a
library called deep learn dot js.
That was an impressive
contribution to the field,
allowing developers to build
machine learning models in
the browser and it had a
few impressive demos associated with it,
like one that let any user train a model
in real time for image classification.
But a lot of the code was deprecated
and Buggy, so an upgrade was in order.
They made it faster,
made the syntax more readable and added
lots of new low level functions to it
that let developers build very
detailed models in the browser,
eventually renaming the
project to tensorflow. Dot.
JS If we build an AI app
using tensorflow dot js,
it makes predictions and trains
itself entirely client's side.
That means it can use the GPU of whatever
user accesses the APP and it doesn't
have to be an Nvidia
Gpu, Jensen, you bad ass.
It can be any kind of GPU from a Mac book,
Gpu to an android phone,
Gpu usually to consume ml models whether
as a developer or as an end user we'd
have to install a few packages or deal
with some sort of technical issue,
but because tensorflow dot
js works in the browser,
we don't have to install any dependencies.
The library is split up
into two different packages.
The first is core,
which is a flexible low level API.
It's syntactically pretty similar
to the tensorflow python library.
Then there's the layers API,
which is similar to care os it's higher
level and makes it easier to build
models at the expense of fine
grain control over the details.
There's a lot of potential for using
client side data to help train models.
It really opens up a whole
new world of machine learning.
One where we can start thinking more about
how server sent events can be used to
feed rich data into these models in real
time while operating in the browser.
We can create apps that continuously
learn and even if users have only a small
amount of data to give,
we can use the library's ability to
perform transfer learning to augment an
existing models capability with new data.
We can even load model
files trained in tensorflow,
python or c plus plus
directly to the browser,
and because the data never leaves
the client, it's privacy friendly.
We can train our models on data clients
side without ever seeing the actual data
itself.
There's a lot of potential
to use tensorflow dot js
to create web apps that can
learn from their users.
You can crowdsource the training of a
music generating AI by having the users
make their own songs in the browser,
have users submit articles and create an
AI that learns to write in the same way
they do or even learn from users browsing
habits to present them with content
that's most suitable for them.
When it comes to installing
tensorflow dot js,
we don't even have to do anything.
If we create a simple html file,
we can access it by simply adding a
script tag to our code that points to the
library online.
Then we can use the library
right under that as a test,
we can write a basic html file that
simply prints out a tenser and in our
javascript console in the browser, we
can see that it works. No dependencies,
no other scripts to run too legit to quit.
Let's look at some of the core
components of the library.
The reason it's called tensorflow.
Dot.
JS is because deep learning models are
essentially a graph of computations.
That is, we have some input data. This
could be an image or a piece of text.
All of this could be represented
by a series of numbers.
We feed that input data into a
computing graph. At each step,
we perform a series of mathematical
operations on that input data,
slowly transforming it and we call
the data that flows through the graph
tensors.
Since a tensor is a group
of numbers in n dimensions,
that can be one dimension
or a hundred dimensions.
The tensors flow through the graph,
eventually producing an output tensor,
which is the prediction that
it makes in tensorflow dot. Js.
The primary unit of data
is called the tensor,
which we can access very easily.
It's a self named a tensor instance has
a shape attribute that defines the array
shape. It's found in the
TF dot tents or function.
We can create tensors of any size.
We just have to define how many dimensions
we'd like as well as the values that
make up the tensor.
If we want to get more specific
and make the code more readable,
we can use other functions like TF dot
tents or Wendy or TF dot tents or Tootie
that specify that the tents are in.
Question is have one or two
dimensions respectively.
Tensors are also immutable,
meaning once they're created,
we cannot change their value.
Instead we can perform operations
on them generating new tensors,
but there should be some mutability when
building a machine learning model right
after all the model must
update itself as it learns.
That's where variables come into play.
Variables are initialized
with a tensor of values,
but unlike tensors,
their values are mutable.
We can assign a new tense
or to an existing variable
using the assigned method.
They're used to store and update
values during model training.
But remember that tensors are
only half of the equation here.
We need to perform operations on them
for this to be machine learning slash for
us to be cool.
Operations or ops for short allow
us to manipulate the tensors.
The library offers a huge range of ops
that allow us to perform fast matrix math
on tensors easily performing calculations
on groups of numbers in parallel.
And because it's a changeable API,
we can call ops on the result of ops on
the result of ops on the result of you
get the point. So what does
building a model actually look like?
In tensorflow dot js,
we've got two options.
The first is to use ops directly to
represent the work the model does.
This is the low level part of the API.
We can define in detail every
ad multiplication, subtraction,
operation that's applied to our tensors
in what order, how often, et cetera.
Alternatively,
if we want to quickly prototype and
model and don't care too much about the
details,
we can use the high level API using TF
dot model to construct a model out of
layers.
These are a popular abstraction in deep
learning adapted from the [inaudible]
library in that a neural network consists
of layers of operations and while
sometimes a layer needs to be written
out as multiple lines of code,
a high level version of this allows the
developer to define a layer as a single
line of code specifying the
necessary parameters right there.
All right? All right. All right.
Let's get to our demo of having an AI
predict what type of object is on our
Webcam.
We'll use a popular machine learning
model called Yolo or you only look once.
The way it works is that it first divides
a given image up into a grid of 13 by
13 cells.
Each of these cells is responsible
for predicting five bounding boxes.
A bounding box describes the
rectangle that encloses the object.
The model will output a confidence
score that tells us how certain that the
predicted bounding box
actually encloses some object.
Once it does that, it'll look something
like this for each downing box.
The cell also predicts a class as
in what it thinks that object is.
It gives a probability distribution
over all the possible classes,
and it does this after having been trained
on a Dataset that contains a set of
labeled image classes.
The confidence score for the bounding
box and the class prediction are combined
into one final score.
That tells us the probability that this
bounding box contains a specific type of
object. Since most of the boxes will
have very low confidence scores,
we only keep the boxes whose
final score is 30% or more,
which leaves us with a final prediction.
The architecture of Yolo is pretty simple.
It's just a convolutional neural network.
I have an incredibly detailed
video on comp nets on my channel.
See the link in the video
description for more, but it's got,
it's got just a couple of these layers
repeated over and over and over again.
We give the network an input image and
in a single pass it will output a tensor
that describes the bounding
boxes for the grid cells.
Then all we'll need to do is compute the
final scores for the bounding boxes and
throw away the ones that
aren't above our threshold,
but since we don't know how
fast a user's GPU will be,
we'll use a tiny version of
this model called tiny Yolo,
which uses fewer layers and is faster,
but also a bit less accurate.
We can import this model into
tensorflow dot js easily.
Then access our Webcam programmatically
to retrieve the image frame.
We can apply each image to our Yolo model
in real time and have the bounding box
layered on top of the image for us to see.
Since the model is already trained,
we don't need to train it.
We're just repurposing it
for use in the browser.
So now it'll tell me whatever it is
that I'm putting in front of the Webcam.
T three things to keep in mind
from this video. Tensorflow. Dot.
Js is the javascript version of Google's
popular at machine learning library,
consisting of both a low level core
API and a high level layers API from
building and training models.
It uses the user's Gpu no matter what
kind for both training and inference,
which opens up a whole
new world of possibility,
including training on real time data.
And we can port existing ml models to
the js framework and repurpose them for
browser use pretty easily. If you want
to learn more, hit the subscribe button.
And for now I've got to use tensorflow
dot. Js so thanks for watching.